this is the picture the palace wants to
show Lady Susan Hussey saying sorry to
ingosi Fulani it was we're told a
meeting filled with warmth and
understanding but it's also a public
apology for racism from the core of the
royal Circle
I think this hopefully draws kind of the
end of this this uh this story really
because you know there's been the
apology and I think from ghost's point
of view she didn't want this to be a big
story she was just really unfortunately
appalled by her treatment on that day
and just wanted to kind of raise
awareness of this
it was this reception that Buckingham
Palace where the pair last met Lady
Susan repeatedly asking and gozi where
she came from speaking at the time she
said the questioning was insulting and
traumatizing made worse by confusion
over attempts to apologize
let's make something clear Buckingham
Palace have not reached out to me I
haven't heard anything from
anybody maybe they've attempted to but
they haven't got through to me or to
Sister space so I don't know where
that's come from but now a joint
statement from Buckingham Palace and Ms
fellani saying lady Susan has pledged to
deepen her awareness of the
sensitivities involved and is grateful
for the opportunity to learn more about
the issues in this area Miss villani who
has unfairly received the most appalling
torrent of abuse on social media and
elsewhere has accepted this apology and
appreciates that No Malice was intended
perhaps unintentional but her careless
comments left the royal family accused
of institutional racism Lady Susan was
the Queen's closest confidante and
Prince William's godmother
she resigned but The Rao raged on and of
course we'd heard these accusations
before Harry and Megan both speaking out
about racism within the palace
the King on the front foot said he was
pleased both parties reached a welcome
outcome and his household now making
moves to show learning from this harmful
and hurtful episode Laura bundock Sky
News